[Music]
and peace out is he's [ __ ] submitted by
tacca the little bill oh my god
[Music]
here are five signs it's time to quit
your job I'm ready to quit my job Oh
which one everything well guys it was
nice I hope you guys enjoyed the channel
no you guys keep doing it they're not
ready to be without you my friend oh I'm
just gonna quit and then rehire myself
there you go I'll quit for one hour you
gonna sit yourselves down in a room I'm
gonna put myself on timeout and stare at
the wall oh you can fire yourself in the
mirror look in here you worthless piece
of [ __ ]
alright number one if your work is
making you physically ill oh my yeah but
what if people have to work in nuclear
facilities you maybe you should try to
find a different one different job it's
not even that - there's like people who
get like physical like ailments just
from the stress and how much they hate
their job alone yeah I I think that
happens a lot because stress hurts your
immune system and then like people's
bodies start breaking down obvious Baca
not for a lot of people obviously I
remember working graveyard shift at
restaurants because the money was really
[ __ ] good but then I would never see
Sun and then I was I got like bronchitis
or some [ __ ] that lasted for months that
led to piece of my nasal like I I blew
my nose in a [ __ ] piece of flesh came
out oh my god it looked like chicken
guts and heart and stuff but what it was
is a bacteria that turned into an actual
like it looked like a piece of organ or
whatever that was just bacteria it
wasn't your eyes yeah it turned it goes
into your sinus and it starts forming
into like like it looked like baby lungs
and chicken heart and gizzard and
everything that's when you had a ziploc
right yeah and I took it to the ER
because I thought that a piece of my
brain just [ __ ] fell out put it back
in I shoot you not dude I freak the [ __ ]
out man like that was some scary [ __ ]
tell the guy hey man I think some of my
brains shot out yeah I was like is this
important do I need this back in my
system cuz like I had I had this stuffy
nose for like two months
and then I just kept [ __ ] this [ __ ] so I
just went huh and then it just blew out
of my nose
and it looked like little lungs and
little [ __ ] livers and everything and
I was could you breathe it was amazing I
could breathe but I was still freaking
out and so anyways you're like there's
too much weight coming in now same
question if the doctor told you that the
only way to get it back into your brain
was that you hate it and swallowed it
would you have done I would have been
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] lyin
that's not how it works but I want to
swallow that though if that is the way
if that was scientifically the way out
it was pretty showed it to us I showed
it to you God did I save it how big was
that harder I remember seeing it I think
it was like that quarter size it wasn't
a babe it wasn't a baby no it was like
yeah it was like this and it had little
parts to it yeah so yeah bacteria can
can become like an organism like it fit
within your [ __ ] sinus but that's how
[ __ ] up it was so I had to take like
antibiotics all these things recover and
then I was like man this job is killing
me I didn't know where to get another
you're saying that as you were spinning
your gold chain around your neck no I
barely made ran in all that to like I
was working a restaurant job you know
like it was good but it wasn't good do
you know what deadly job is [ __ ]
underwater see welding that sounds fun
oh yeah ocean crabbing oh yeah most
dangerous job in the world I love that
show why is it so dangerous people fly
off and they die fly off of what the
boat because it's like Ricky rocking
around because the place out there at
the waves are [ __ ] Oh
it's like water splashing onto it all
the time they also don't [ __ ] sleep
ever right they said like an hour at a
time and like the only way they keep
themselves awake is caffeine and a lot
of food so these constantly eat and
they're just wet and cold to for 12
hours straight because you just you
can't stay dry on there pretty crazy
what kind of crap I feel bad now the
delicious will never get in Vegas with
the big legs just know when you're
eating it someone [ __ ] died that year
that's right it's guaranteed deaths
every year but what most people do is
like they'll get that job they'll crank
it out for a couple of years and then
they try to leave they leave all the
money is so [ __ ] good as hard I'd
rather deal drugs to hipsters it's more
lucrative and safe I hear you the safest
[ __ ] in the world you have customers
that have a lot of money and they're
nonviolent and they're scared of every
little physical confrontation that could
ever have that's true and they drive
golf carts yeah are like the equivalent
they're smart cars of course you do oops
Jeff is [ __ ] working with extreme
prejudice right here she's waiting for
the mistake she was like target acquired
just throw away all my data's not fat
anymore Tim yeah all persons my whole
life takes a lot - yeah you lost 40
pounds of shoes thrown it out the window
like it's nothing okay
dude he's like the guy in Indiana Jones
who looked at the [ __ ] light his face
like [ __ ] melts in the skull skeleton
okay number two the next promotion isn't
all that attractive oh yeah that's how
the truth have you ever been in a job
where you're like I don't want to be
promoted because that's like the title
with less money or the money's not even
that worth it and you're just like the
bronze white house that was my thing
anytime I see shift manager I'm always
like oh that would suck
cuz think about it you have to set
everyone's schedules may have to like
make sure everyone's on there's guys
you're just more responsible more
headache but then you don't even get
compensated that much yeah if you still
work it like a fast-food place like
you're barely getting compensated for
that [ __ ] and if it doesn't work out
they [ __ ] hate your guts number
three your life is much different now
what do you mean for the better although
they're saying that people go through
changes especially in personality in the
shift in mindset is a slow process but
there's a strong possibility you're not
the same person who accepted this job
five or ten years ago
so if you worked at the same job for
more than a decade you're definitely not
the same in the same place in life and
so maybe a different job would be better
fitting to who you are now I like
becoming customer service and [ __ ] and
doing 10 years of that you just [ __ ]
hate people when you used to love people
that's why you signed up for customer
service because you wanted to help
people and she is one of our barbell
staffs husband he was like super Wall
Street style like that was his old job
he was like never home and he was like
hustling like crazy within the minute
that had like three kids he wanted to be
like a stay-at-home dad and he just
realized that that always being away
from home lifestyle wasn't good for him
and then he like drastically reduced his
pay and then it was home now but this is
for people who have a little bit more
freedom to choose because sometimes like
you just got to take what have a [ __ ]
job you can get and just suck it the
[ __ ] up until you can get out bar cuz
you're like you'd like started as like
JK films guy and now you're you're like
Instagram like a [ __ ] Fitness guy
like on Instagram not completely but a
little bit but you don't say yeah we're
like your Instagram maybe like five
years ago would have been like bits and
like like little skit skits and [ __ ]
yeah yeah but now it's like all fit in
this visually true sometimes you just
gotta bite the bullet you gotta run away
from YouTube for a couple years and just
have nothing in your bank account that's
the David's omegap it and then finally
at the two years you feel the [ __ ]
power to do videos again it only took a
good seven hundred days I'm back baby
well I mean that's hard being your own
job maker with really nobody on your
team and you try to build one and they
all [ __ ] the [ __ ] Sun all I'm saying
is you had to go through a lot yeah
that's pretty tough dude yeah man it was
it was interesting though it's like kind
of like stepping away from something
that you hated though made you come it
also gave me perspective it's like oh
actually don't hate YouTube I hate what
I was doing at the time yeah you know
and I wanted to do other things so I did
it that
checked it off and now that it's checked
off I can come back to something I owe
ya we liked so what I wanted to do was
it being done so I started hating
something I should liked you all so
convinced all your best team members to
pursue other things do ya keep your
dream anchor dude I see this spark and
I'm like this is not for you you should
do this is that's true that's why you
keep having to find new people because
you like tell them to go away and pursue
their dreams Ghandi dream crusher yeah I
never accomplished that you could only
work for me forever you even got one of
our guys to go pursue being a doctor
which one good old Daniel he's one of
the original Jake in his editors one of
the original now he's gonna be a doctor
what a loser right no I wasn't cuz I
David yeah wasn't that because of me
alright number four your side job is
taken off so if your side job is pulling
in decent money and you're way more
and/or enjoyable yeah yeah I think you
should quit your full-time gig that's
pretty obvious like your side job makes
more than one of the your main job not
more money just enough to survive off
yeah
that's positive I love the idea of
somebody googling that my side jobs
doing more butter than my regular job
what should I do
yeah sometimes people have that loyalty
mentality where they don't want to let
their prior team down so even though
they know in their brain that this is
the right thing to do they're like [ __ ]
but I don't want to let my team down him
but that's trifling he should have let
them know that's true because I knew I
was gonna leave my job eventually but
then yeah I give him like enough time
like a couple months I make sure that
like someone's trained at what I was
doing so then if I do leave it doesn't
hurt the company or they don't have to
scrounge like oh [ __ ] last minute we got
to figure out how to do his job or
whatever and I think that's just the
best way to exit anything and the last
reason here is number five you hate
explaining what you do for work oh I
love explaining what I do for work yeah
Wayne it I love it with people go do you
really make money doing that right and I
go for tons [ __ ] time
like like comedy Oh like I feed like 30
people homie when people say ask you
what you do for a living what do you say
I say writer comedian host doesn't show
like that as a producer when people ask
me they're like what do you do for a
living I was like I don't know a couple
of small businesses oh that's nice sound
too important I say I make youtube
videos that's probably why they why do
you make money doing that [ __ ] I don't
do that because then it's gonna open up
a conversation with the puck yeah a
couple days ago
oh and we move on you do you don't say
what kind of music businesses they don't
say that bagel food and they what kind
of food drinks by that saying that you
own own businesses is sounds tight you
don't want to do that you don't want to
sound low and then they look down and
you go I'm better than you like that
feels good I think guys cool well I
would like I'm a youtuber oh really
you're a youtuber
see I would do that if only I made five
tons of money but like I said I was gone
for two years so could there's a little
bit of a problem Peter Oh save it
seriously
god is pretty bad
[Music]
Oh